wind power for world travel
centuries ago ships just like this here
in New York uh sure to the age of sail
but in this age of technology we're now
using these sails up in space using the
sun's power to power spaceflight liftoff
an Atlas 5 rocket may 20th Cape
Canaveral in its payload this light sail
super thin super light with a reflective
mylar film a sail that catches the Sun
and so if the force is constant from
sunlight
NASA's less Johnson is an expert on
solar sails at the Marshall Space Flight
Center in Huntsville Alabama he explains
that lights pushes it's a very very
small push it's on the order of a few
ounces per football field but when you
get up into space
if you unfurl a lightweight reflector
and have sunlight on it it's going to
move Johnson says think of the sun's
energy like little pellets from a BB gun
propelling a sail through space
we can go faster than any rocket humans
have ever made to Pluto for example
saying at 2 or 3 years as opposed to 7
to 11 years depending on the size of the
sale now what would this do well it
takes you to where you want to go so one
mission that's being talked about is to
rendezvous with Halley's Comet Carl
Sagan brought the idea to the masses on
the Johnny Carson show in 1976 but in
application the human race is only about
five years into experiments with solar
sails the first to fly was Japan's
Icarus in 2010 for about 16 million
dollars nASA has invested 25 million
over the last two decades launching a
solar sail into orbit to prove space
deployment in 2010 - this past winter
NASA tried to follow with sunjammer but
that mission had to be scrapped light
sails success this month is welcome news
NASA's Johnson is excited for two
reasons
it'll eventually let us go to the Stars
and the other is I think it lets us cut
that cord with the earth and not have to
worry about bringing everything with us
following the path of science fiction
from Star Wars to Star Trek
solar sails are quickly becoming science
fact it might take us across a solar
system in the next hundred years